[Music]
Jim we're talking this season about less
is more in a way it's less color is more
you've bleached out these colors what do
you call these the dusties the dusties
why do you love it so much this season
and what should we know about I feel
it's like such a great movement I mean
guys are going to see a lot of these
colors in the stores they're not going
to really know how to put it together at
this point you've got a pair of white
jeans you got a pair of khakis you
probably have a pair of fatigue pants
think about a different color palette
don't always pull out the khakis and put
them with like the white polo shirt
think of them in a way as primary colors
that complement each other but they're
not primary they're dusted down because
they have that sun blasted feel they're
sort of they're they are neutrals you
could wear most of these shirts with
jeans well as well as khakis but it
looks dressier it looks snappier it's a
whole different way of of uh of having
your style this season it's a very easy
look to pull off you know a green always
works with an orange a blue works with a
red or a pink and a yellow always works
with a blue and then to neutralize it
also you know with with a d-ring belt or
you know it looks great with kind of a
faded leather belt I think another great
point that I I want to get to this
season that you we've shown in the pages
of the magazine give your blue jeans a
rest nothing wrong with wearing denim
all the time but in the summer you have
the option to give a dressier casual
pant which really gives you a whole
different look we love jeans and we're
not saying throw out your jeans but
wouldn't it be nice to just actually
give them a rest give them like the
summer off let's say right you have
three different pant shapes here you've
got the the cargo which is a little bit
more of the utility pants you've got the
Chino on Clint in the middle and then RJ
on the end is wearing the the quide
could see you know wearing these on a
date on a Friday or Saturday night out
on the beach you don't want to pack
something formal but you know you throw
in your your jacket you go down into
town and you look Chic and sophisticated
you don't look like the average American
you look look like the talent at Mr
riple 2013 it's all about the dusties
it's all about the
dusties get that dust off dust off see
it made him
laugh someone thinks I'm funny that's it
yep you heard it colors dust it off and
you'll be looking stylish this spring
and summer into a warm
[Music]
weather